you
[Music]
and my talk today is about hindsight
bias and how we how to deal with label
you could chat scale so I'm a senior
data scientist at celso's I walk on the
Einstein team dance and PadFone team
where we mostly work on automating
machine learning at scale and to kind of
just give a brief introduction of like
what else does - can I give you a
background of you know all this data
comes from and what the problems that we
deal with we have a cm company and we
have a ton of data a ton of different
kind of data so we have Overlake you
know every day like more than 3 million
new opportunities guy created one in two
million leads get created and this is
like every single day and I'm currently
Einstein gives about 3 billion
predictions a day - so just to give you
an idea of like the kind of the scale
that we have to deal with you and also
even though I assume most people here
familiar but can I like the typical
machine learning pipeline and you know
you do your ETL you do some data
cleaning then the engineer your features
you do some model training and model
evaluation this is kinda like a cycle
that go on until you're like happy with
you know how you model the fonts and
then you deploy the model in some shape
and form and once it's in production you
can Alex go and updates the model give
scores like whatever frequency you want
and update the models necessary and of
course this is kinda like there's only
like a cycle between the training and
evaluation here but of course you can I
lead go back and forth between different
things sometimes you go back to like the
feature engineering sometimes to go back
to the data cleaning and so on and the
problem that we had is that while in our
case we don't just have like one
customer or one use case we have like
hundreds of customers and each customer
has multiple use cases so you kinda have
to multiply this pipeline by the number
of customers and a number of use cases
so now you don't have one pipeline you
have hundreds of pipelines and this is
kind of problematic in our case because
well there's simply not enough data
scientists to work on each of these
models and hence unit and they go
through this pipeline can
individually right so you also don't
know often the specific use case of the
model so every time and you did a data
scientists would work on a model you
would have to like sit down learn about
the company you learn about the data and
then try to build like the best model so
kind of the conclusion that we had here
was that each step in this pipeline that
I showed you how to be automated because
otherwise you just can't really deploy
anything it's also another problem that
we had is that the data is very messy
data so if you work for you know a
company where you collect your own data
and you create you can attic produce
that data you have some control over
like how this data gets generated and
how would you know what whatever you
mean what shape and form first well the
data comes from customers right
customers who use cell service and no
one really likes data entry since a lot
of this data is general is well it's
manual data entry so often that's like
missing fields someone doesn't fill in
the field correctly or it has typos so
you have a string did you know 99% of
the time matches not a string but not
quite
there's like one or two typos in there
you also have automated business
practices so not everything is manual
you have some practices that you know
where fields get generated automatically
or get filled in automatically you like
you know someone fills in an email on a
form all of those fields then get
populated cells form and this is also
problematic sometimes because depending
on who fills out the form or where this
form comes from you know there will be
patterns in the data that for you when
you just look at it you don't really
know why this pattern exists but if you
know who generates this data and how you
realize there's some kind of pattern in
them also Celsus is very customizable so
think of it as like a giant spreadsheet
where you can add columns and we can
remove them or you can just not use them
at some point and we have customers that
have like six to eight hundred columns
and it doesn't surprise you probably if
I tell you that not all 800 columns are
used at the same time for every single
row
another problem is that we usually don't
have any historical data so this means
that for each of these columns in each
of these fields that I'm talking about
we don't have like a change log of all
kinetic you know breached which value
gets updated when it's kind of
impossible to keep track of that so we
only ever get the data at like a
snapshot time this is you know as of
today this is what the data look like we
don't know really about it look five
minutes ago unless we also happen to
pull the data five minutes ago which
means we have a big call start problem
we get the data we only know like hey
this is what it looks like now we can't
really go back and see what happened
before so this was just kind of to give
you a background of like that thick type
of data that we deal with and kind of
like what some problems are with it and
the reason I'm giving you this
background is that this really led to a
lot of hindsight bias um also known as
label leakage or data leakage we're
really we have this massive problem of
messy data that leads to this and so
what is ladel leakage I'm using an
example here from Back to the Future the
second part which is little more unknown
but basically here you know Marty McFly
travels into the future he obtains the
sports Almanac which has all the results
from all the sports games from leaked
you know of the future he goes back in
time he loses it
some guy picks it up and he bets on all
the games and he obviously events every
single time which is great for him but
creates a lot of problems in the
universe so that is basically what label
leakage is it's knowing things that you
shouldn't know because they actually
happen in the future so to give you an
example which is very classic it's using
the Titanic data set which I you see
most of you are familiar with it's
something you can get from Kaggle except
what they don't tell you on Cagle is
that there's several columns missing
which I will go into later but what
you're doing here is just predicting to
survival on the Titanic so what you can
see it's very easy then there's some
very straightforward kinetic statistics
here is if you're male
you had a higher likelihood of actually
not surviving if you have a female you
had a higher likelihood of surviving if
you were in first class this is also
like all not you know super surprising
but if you're in first class you also
had a higher likelihood of surviving
compared to many wearing that dress
right this is all very straightforward
this is all something you can kind of
like tell when you do exploratory
analysis so now what they didn't tell
you when you got that data sitting on
Kegel is that there was also this column
here which was a called a body number
and when you look at it and you look at
when this column is filled out and when
it's empty so it's a numerical field but
when you look at it I mean you see is
there a body number present or not but
you realize is well if the body number
is foldout you didn't survive if there
isn't one you know then 58 percent
didn't survive so a body number is
simply when you look at the description
of the data it's wall it's kind of
macabre but it's basically they assigned
you a number man to your corpse and then
you die so obviously when you have a
body number you died everybody should
you know look at some less macabre
visits and there's a similar there
column here which is the boat number
this is the boat this can like the boat
that you were on when you got off the
ship right so here again when you didn't
have a boat number 97% didn't survive
it's not quite as straightforward it's
the body number but it has like a very
similar can I like a very similar
distribution so what is the problem with
these two well the problem is when
you're actually in this case when you
want to make the prediction is that well
the for this prediction time you know
what the gender of the passenger is you
know what the passenger class is you
have a bunch of more information about
it right
however whether you have a boat number a
body number that's kind of like after
the prediction time right
this is after the event actually
happened this is it after the you know
after you crashed into the iceberg so
when you make the prediction using
anything that happened before the
prediction time is fine but using stuff
that happened afterwards this is kinetic
a sports Almanac you can't really use
this because this is information is not
really available at the time you want to
make the prediction so a more you know
less macabre and more modern example is
let's say install suppose you want to
predict whether a lead converts to a
customer so we have a bunch of
information on here right like what what
industry is this customer and what's the
name what is the annual revenue of this
company you know all of this stuff so
this is something this is whatever it
looked like before a conversion you know
after the conversion it's very similar
except nowadays like a new feel deal
value and this is basically the
equivalent of like the boat number right
there is only this field is only filled
out if you actually convert it to be a
customer if you didn't convert the deal
value is blank there is no deal there's
nothing there's no value right so if I
tell you well you can use if you just
use this as a predictor in your machine
learning model the machine learning
model will be very smart and say well if
there's a deal value you will be a big
customer right you will become a
customer but that's not really helpful
when you actually try to give that
prediction to a new customer right so
why does this kind of matter it's great
for betting it's unfortunately not so
great for machine learning and it has a
big effect on kind of your model
performance and the model performance is
obviously what eventually this is what
you care about so when you do
traditional machine learning evaluation
you split up your data into into
training and whole dog set right and
because the model relies on information
that's not actually available at scoring
time the the model performance here
suffers but the problem is when you
use the training and the holdout set
they're both from the same point in time
which means that your plot when you just
like plot the training and the holder
accuracy metric whatever your accuracy
metric is you know you'll look the same
it's kind of like any other plot that
you both see so you know you can kind of
ignore the y-axis but basically all the
shows it's like well fall if these
remodels your training accuracy is
pretty good and then in the holdout it
slightly decreases or stays very similar
and then you can kind of like decide
whether you want to ship this or not
right but the problem is this isn't when
you have this label leakage this doesn't
really tell you anything because the
data is from the same point in time
which means that the holdout set also
has this leakage information if I train
because you train on data from this
point in time which means they either
convert or they didn't so they have this
information available they have these
leakers in there so what you have to do
now is called something it's just
time-based evaluation which is more
predicting the real reality of what
actually happened which means you look
at you need to look at each record
separately and you need to score and
evaluate at different times instead of
at the same time like you do in two
holdout set but you score on the holdout
set and you evaluate on the holdout set
so this is a little bit more kind of a
more complicated plot but basically what
you see here is four time points t 0 2 t
3 it doesn't really matter what they are
and you have some records so you can see
at T 0 a B and C is your training set
there your positive and negative
examples and de and F there this is what
you would want to predict right these
are like the ones but you don't know
what the outcome is so in the
traditional machine learning model what
you would do is exactly that you would
train on a DS well you would split up a
B and C into leghole that training you
were trained on like that's a and B and
you would you hold that set for PC right
and this would be like your accuracy and
then you get any would predict the EMF
so for this however what you would do
it's actually well yeah let's look so at
t zero what you would do is train an a b
and c like you would perform or rather
you split it up and you still do across
as ever m cross-validation and then what
you do is go on d and e so why nots go
on f well f actually never converts if
you look at like t1 t2 and t3 you never
actually know if it converts or not so
this is something that you can run in
about an evaluation on because you don't
know the label at the end you can
however let's go on D in E and you do
that because then you can at t1 you can
actually evaluate D and E which means
you take the label a time of t1 which
here in this case means D is converted
and II did not convert and you compare
it to the prediction that you gave at t
0 and at the same time you now have a
new Rho G which enters kinetic the
business and you can see that it's not
compare mean it's it's something you
want to predict at t1 and it doesn't
convert at t2 so you score it and then
again at t2 you can evaluate it and you
don't score and here this is kind of one
of the key things to you can see I which
also is a new row at t1 but you don't
actually scored us at t1 you score it at
t2 which is kind of like the latest this
is the latest update something happened
at t2 some some field was changed and
then you can evaluate it finally at t3
so it's at each row you base you have to
check when did this you find rows to
evaluate on that weren't converted at t0
whenever you train your model and at
some point afterwards did convert and
then you basically take the latest
change before dis conversion you can
take a random one m2 and score on that
and that ensures that there's no leakage
information in there
because you purposefully exclude
anything that happened after the lead
converted are there any questions on
that
a lot of information fun so make sense
so you don't ball in this case you
wouldn't retrain it because you don't
have to retrain on a B's a B and C
because they don't change so usually
after the RO converts that can Alex
stable and the rules don't really change
anymore but you could if you have more
data at t1 and if you have more rows you
could retrain a model ok so and usually
now what the plot looks like of your
accuracy metric is while a training and
hold out you kind of see a very familiar
picture your accuracy metric well you
know go down a little bit it's kind of
say the same but now at evaluation you
can see this is green and the red model
the accuracy goes down a lot and for the
blue one it doesn't so the reason here
is that for the green in the right one
those are models that had label leakage
in it and that means the model picked up
on his label leakage and in the training
and the holdout set the information was
there we knew by that there was a lead
value or not but then on the evaluation
data that value was always empty right
so if the machine learning model says
well if this field if this lead value
field is filled out you're more likely
to be on the customer and then all of
your evaluation data that field is empty
it will obviously bias it towards saying
you did not convert even though maybe it
actually did right so your accuracy you
see this very kinetic massive drop in
your accuracy metric and blue that would
be kind of like 1 but you don't have
label leakage you don't see this massive
drop in the accuracy metric and that's
obviously what you want because when you
serve this model you want to make sure
that it you know reflects reality of
what will actually happen and yes so
there's no the leakers are not in the
evaluation
by definition so how do you actually now
solve this problem and there are some
solutions and then obviously there's
always more problems that you cannot
realize that come along once you have
some solutions so this is some kind of
data set that we would have to deal with
so you have some IDs obviously you have
your name address phone and a bunch of
other columns and now you have something
that's called close by recent lost
amount and then you know whether delete
convert it or not just like a simple
boolean field true false false true
false so now if you look at this you
should be able to pick out some problems
with this data so the first one is that
if you look at reason last well if this
field is filled out that means you're
always never converted right this is
basically some automated business that
says well if I lost this is an automated
process if I lost this lead while
obviously it didn't convert you lost it
for example to some competitor and they
turned you down them into a competitor
or for some unknown reason if the amount
is filled in this is basically like that
this lead value thing right so if this
is filled in it means that delete always
converted which makes sense
if you convert there's some kind of like
value associated with you and close by
is a little bit more tricky but you can
see that at least in this example like 2
out of 3 times when it's filled out you
also convert it only in one of this case
it didn't convert so this is also it
could be some automatic practice some
automated process where once you kinetic
some person goes in and closes it this
is like the IDE linking to this person
and maybe some of them never get close
because you know you enter a lot of
leads not all of them for some of them
you never know whether they can only
convert or not and they might still be
in your database a year after and
logically you know as a human you say of
all they're not a customer it
fine because they have a positively
united agreement but to the machine
learning model you don't know so the
problem with this is that a lot of times
these features are simply too good but
at I mean they don't carry actually well
when you do like statistical tests on
them they will pop up as having a really
high correlation and what we do here is
we take the rotate we generate of
features which also usually Auto
generate it for example just legs and
one hard encoding for categorical data
sometimes you know you know but it's an
email or not so you can extract the
email domain and then can I lick one
hutton code that we can extract country
codes and then kind of the key for a lot
of this is we also have a null indicator
so for every feature that we have we add
a column you know one hard encoded
column whether this feature is null or
not and then based on that we can
calculate the correlation with the label
which would be that like Pearson's or
Aramis Li for categorical data and we
basically calculated threshold of what
this over which threshold we will
exclude all of these features and the
child features so what this means is
that you know if there's a high
correlation between whether the field is
filled out or not and a label let's say
0.9 we can save all this feature is a
little suspicious because it has too
high of a correlation and we throw it
out you just remove it from the training
set the problem with this is obviously
that once you go into something it's
threshold based you never really know
what the threshold should be because you
obviously want to keep good features you
know I want to keep the leakers but you
want to make sure that if there's a
strong signal in the data that's like
point you know has a correlation of like
0.7 this might actually be really about
good feature that you want to keep so
once we kind of looked at this we
realized it solved a lot of the more
obvious examples you know if your
correlation is 0.99 and it's pretty
obvious that more maybe this is
something you have to either examine or
just remove but unfortunately because
the
data that we deal with is really messy
it didn't actually solve everything that
we had to deal with so in this example
yeah when you feel expected revenue and
you can see it's never now it's always
filled out there's no one else but this
is because the default value is not
always null sometimes it's zero or
sometimes it's I don't know some other
value like the customer can pick and
choose whatever the default value is and
we don't know so in this case a volume
that is bigger than zero always
indicates conversion this is basically
the same thing as like these values that
I've talked about before right so if
there's an expected revenue then it
means you did convert to be a customer
if the expected revenue is zero it means
you didn't actually become a customer or
we want to give you a prediction
probability that you actually convert so
if we just calculate the correlation now
between this column and the label there
won't be anything suspicious about it
because it'll treated like animal like a
numeric feature and you know it'll just
give you some correlation value that's
probably not really high but what you
can do is you can packetize this so you
can basically make a histogram and you
can do this based on the data so what we
do here is we use a decision tree to add
a bucket is these features and then you
can catch them through the correlation
check so here you can see the new column
at it which is the same expected revenue
column after you Backa ties it it has
three values the third one is this null
indicator that I talked about and you
can see it's zero for all of them
because well none of them I actually
know and the first one basically is the
first bucket then the second one is the
second bucket and here it would mean the
first bucket is everything that's minus
infinity to zero
including and the second bucket is
everything over zero and here the key
thing is we didn't have a data scientist
go in and kind of like create these
buckets because again we would have
hundreds of cases where you would have
to figure out what these histogram
buckets should be right
so if you just came out by the way where
you just look at the data the algorithm
looks like the data and auto back
addresses it automatically and then what
happens is you this is now a categorical
variable you can calculate promise v
between which is basically the same
thing as well the equivalent of Pearson
correlation and you can then again use
the threshold and say if it's above this
threshold discard is variable and as a
nice bonus these actually work really
well for model performance - turns out
all the packet icing is often better
than just using the actual numeric value
as your feature
so far we've really only looked at kind
of like data points at one specific
point in time right we only looked at
like a static example of data the
problem is that while training the data
that you trained on and the scoring data
that you want to actually give
predictions for it already produced at
the same time the training data is
always historical because you know what
the outcome is right you know whether
the lead converted or not but the
scoring data is more recent this is what
you want to give the predictions for no
one really comes to us and says hey can
you not give us a prediction for a lead
that was generated like two years ago
because at that point they don't care
anymore right even though theoretically
that it could still convert and become a
customer so the problem here is that we
realized there's a massive discrepancy
sometimes in these leakage fields
between the training that training set
and the scoring set in terms of the fill
rate so here in the first example you
have a field that's always filled out in
the training set but it's never filled
out in the scoring set it could be
something like this body number right
it's just simply you don't have this
information for all of the rows that you
want a prediction for so we looked at
this and we decided well in that case
let's just route its column because no
matter what inside you gain from this
column and the training set it's not
transferable to the data that you give a
prediction
which means it doesn't actually help you
at all to give a good prediction so in
the second case we said well the fill
rates are pretty similar so let's keep
them and if that case this is a little
bit more interesting you said well
they're very similar right they're
basically the same but they're really
low and we also excluded it and the
reason here is that usually what we find
out is that when the filler ratio is
really low there's just not really any
that's just not enough information in
them to really drive the predictive
model and I have to also call back too
late you know we have like hundreds of
columns and we generated thousands of
features so we can be pretty liberal at
excluding features this is not something
maybe like throw out massive information
usually and then in the fourth field we
can see that while again it's not
there's a pretty big discrepancy so if
you said you know let's throw this out -
and this seems very counterintuitive to
most data scientists because you know
it's all about like preserving all the
features generating more features but
like I said we have so many features
that well first of all it just helps
greatly with run time and also it
usually this would just really distort
your model and pick up things at
training time that don't actually give
you any help at prediction time here's
another Kanak example of what we had to
deal with with this kind of like very
messy data so on the y-axis you see the
percentage of conversion ranging from x
0 to 1 right and time you can can ignore
it a month it's just like some arbitrary
time on the x-axis and you can see that
for most of the time the conversion kind
of like hovers above like 0.55 like plus
or minus a little bit right but then in
March this is massive spike to 1 every
single year converted in March which is
awesome except it's kind of weird like
why right why is this so biased towards
positive labels
so you actually took in this case we
actually talked to the customer and they
told us well we migrated from a
different system and we couldn't be
extracted all of our you know leads in
the system and we threw out all the ones
that didn't convert because we don't
care about it anymore like you don't why
should I you know import a lead from
five years ago that never converted it's
no longer relevant right but the Machine
and all doesn't know that and unless you
know you have a data scientist who looks
at this data it's also not something
that the machine learning will ever
really know unless you tell it to you
right so in this case you really want to
be careful to use something like the
last modified date or the created date
as kind of like a feature because that
will tell you this is awesome everything
traded and match will convert which is
not actually true right this is not what
happened in reality so here's some
kinetic to sum up this kind of part
about like why or how we exclude things
is that well if there's a low overall
fill ratio in the training in the
scoring set we can exclude this and by
that I mean it's like a very like a 1%
rate or something just just throw it out
there's no point in kind of keeping this
field wrong if there's a big discrepancy
between the training and the scoring
data also throw it out because that's a
really good signal that this is some
kind of liquor where you don't really
have this information what we do here is
we convert the fill rates to probability
distributions and compared with chance
and Shannon divergence so it gives you
like a nice metric where you can
actually set a threshold so this is the
problem with setting thresholds is if
you calculate something where the metric
varies based on the data set and it
doesn't really help you you need
something that has laid at lower and
upper bounds and the third point was
that while some dates can really skew
things and you want to really be careful
about using date features that might be
biased towards either positive or
negative as a feature
and the awesome thing about this
compared to the part where I talked
about the correlations is that this you
don't actually need to do any feature
transformations on this right you don't
need to do one hard encoding you don't
need to do anything you can just use the
raw columns that you get the raw data
you and it's much much quicker to
actually do this and you have future
generations
you know table influenced like your
correlations obviously here it doesn't
actually matter you can just draw
anything at it you can generate fill
rates for anything right so what this is
look like at an actual use case that we
had so here we compare this Auto ml no
other machine learning that can like
these thresholds that we had to a data
scientist who spend I think like one or
two weeks hand tuning a model and mostly
looking at okay give me all the 800
fields that we have in this model and
I'm going to go through each month and
look at these like look at these look at
this data like manually and see whether
I should exclude it or not
so the autumn L removed 73 fields the
data scientists remove 42 and you can
see in this Venn diagram in the middle
that's the overlap so the good thing is
the data scientists definitely found
some things that auto machine learning
also did machine learning found a lot
more and but you can also see that some
that the data scientists removed that we
didn't find with the auto machine and
that's because while the examples I
showed you I can read the more
straightforward ones some of them a
little bit more tricky right when you
set a threshold you say the threshold is
0.7 so now you might have a field that's
like 0.69 and you're like ah well I
guess that's not getting thrown out but
maybe it should right so usually what we
do is once we have a data scientist look
at this we look at all of these fields
and try to come up with general
mechanisms and methods to throw to throw
these fields out it's not always
successful but often it works that's how
we kind of like came up with all the
other methods
so just to kind of like sum up this
quickly and to kind of give some final
thoughts so one of these problems that
I've talked about is the threshold
problem right and this is really because
we have to solve all our customers we
have machine on platform which means
that we don't actually you know we run
we want to really make pipelines for all
the customers that we have we can't you
know have a data scientist pick and
choose the threshold for every single
model but we have to find kind of like
we have to find some thresholds that
work the best for the majority of the
models even if it means that maybe one
or two models might have a better
solution right now I see I forgot the
first part but in general it's just
really tricky to choose when you think
about correlation you know you have to
set the threshold somewhere but you
don't want to go too low because then
you're throwing out really good
predictive features right and in fact
when people uploaded some customers they
wanted to test this and they uploaded
like kaggle data and be throughout they
see everything because there was like
biology data or something and there were
like some really strong predictors in
there where the correlation was like
0.95 and that's what you know is really
good when you know that this isn't alica
but because we deal with enterprise data
usually kind of seem that and because
it's really hard to kind of like chooses
threshold what we try to do now is to do
these smart decisions based on the data
and the data shape so instead of setting
a threshold you want to do something
like Auto packet izing right maybe don't
go in and they tell tell the you know
let's use these buckets you just say let
the algorithm figure it out about the
packets should be based on the data and
basically let all decisions be made by
machine on you and this also means
there's lots of experimentation of
trying out different thresholds
different configurations in different
ways of cash changes and to learn kind
of like these so both to kinda like yeah
find use to fine-tune the thresholds and
also just to kind of like learn some
more you wrist except they can then
translate into machine learning
algorithms so it key takeaways here is
that enterprise data is very messy and
you should be very careful of just like
throwing your standard machine learning
pipeline at it we often have this lake
level leakage and too-good-to-be-true
is a problem when all of your models did
you produce have like a QC metrics of
0.99 you should probably look at it
again and you know not quite trust it
and you can't just like use the normal
evaluation of training and hold out
cross-validation it doesn't work if the
data that you evaluate on also has this
label leakage so you can't actually menu
this is the very annoying pad its menu
first ship a model you know I can't do
this time based evaluation you don't
have like three months of future data so
you can I have to trust your model there
and you kind of like even though the
kinetic the methods that I described
here or it will be straightforward they
were all pretty novel on how to apply
this for label leakage and you're still
kind of working on some more advanced
methods to catch these things so the
good thing is that now you obviously all
want to try this out the good thing is
if you have an open source library
transmogrify and it's built on top of
Spock ml it's a full machine learning
pipeline both of these things that I
talked about can only comparing the
training and the scoring set and you
know based excluding things based on
correlations just expose part of this
probably takes you about 10 lines of
code to do all of this what I talked
about and if you're interested more go
to the github page there's a lot of
stuff on there that you can learn about
and you're also hiring more data
scientists we actually be also hiring
more data engineers and more full-stack
engineers so whatever you are if you
interested in and come talk to me and
yeah that's it thank you very much for
listening and
if there's time for questions yeah we
have a few minutes yeah yeah so the
question was is what if you don't have
the scouring time how do you do the
comparison between the fill rates and
yeah the answers you can't and the good
thing is that in I use case we always
have two training and the scoring set so
that's not something we had to solve and
that was but it was something that it
took us a while to kind of realize that
we had that advantage because usually
you don't have it
[Music]